russia's invasion of ukraine has driven
up the cost of staple foods wheat and
corn prices have reached record highs
developing nations are already feeling
the pain so is global food security at
risk this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo russia's war on ukraine has
created fears of a global food crisis
the two countries supply a third of the
world's wheat and our major exporters of
barley corn and sunflower oil fighting
has disrupted exports and that's led to
record prices on international markets
the cost of wheat is at its highest
level in 14 years corn is at a nine-year
high ukraine sport stopped working when
russia began its invasion last week this
means grain stocks from both countries
aren't reaching their main markets in
the middle east and africa economists
say consumers particularly in lower and
middle income countries will have to pay
higher prices
well let's take a look at how much some
countries rely on russia and ukraine's
wheat many of them are already battling
food shortages egypt is the world's
biggest importer of wheat it gets 85
percent of it from russia and ukraine
the two nations also supply war-ravaged
yemen with 40 percent and ukraine's
wheat makes up around half of lebanon's
needs the country is still recovering
from the beirut port blast in 2020 that
destroyed its main grain silo
if the situation escalates and the wheat
market is halted we have enough for
about months worth of wheat stored in
mills but after that we have no reserves
with war in ukraine and russia our
reserves will drop and instead of
supporting our needs for the next four
years it will only be available for two
or three months
the crisis will affect us and we will
suffer from wheat shortages
because of the war between russia and
ukraine we have fears of a shortage of
flower and wheat but god willing we will
overcome these difficulties
well let's bring in our guest now in
beirut we have patrick mardini an
economist at leaden hall international
for market solutions he's also the
president of the lebanese institute for
market studies in washington dc david
labord a senior research fellow at the
international food policy research
institute and in london dara mcdowell a
geopolitical risk consultant
specializing in russia and the carcasses
a warm welcome to your gentlemen thank
you very much for being on inside story
patrick in beirut let me start with you
lebanon of course relies heavily on
wheat from ukraine it's already facing
a very bad economic crisis
tell us about the situation right now
how worse could it get and what's the
knock-on effect of the war in ukraine on
lebanon
sure so lebanon as you said imports most
of the wheat from ukraine
the disruption in the as of sea and the
black sea are actually impacting the
delivery of feed that have been already
bought
so you have those supply chain chain
problems
uh the ships are being delayed
and uh and the orders are now looking
for alternative from
argentina usa and probably canada for uh
in in in case you have longer war and
more
disruptions so basically if you are
going to import the suite from
alternative places
the prices will be higher
you need to transport them through a
longer route so it's more expensive and
now with the war
increasing the fuel prices worldwide the
transportation cost will be even higher
right so actually we will have a
lebanon with the prices of wheat going
up yeah the economy minister has said
there's a month worth of wheat reserves
left
how will the lebanese government respond
do you think
so that's a big problem because the main
silo that stores wheat has been
destroyed during the explosion of beirut
and indeed now we rely on small storage
facilities in in small mills across
lebanon which can only last for one
month
now the ministry of economy fixes the
prices of wheat if they will keep
sorry so if they will keep the price of
bread low and the price of importing
wheat will be higher the cost of
importing wheat will be higher than the
price then we might have serious
shortages so the ministry should
be courageous and increase the prices in
order to allow covering the higher cost
or else we might end up but an increase
in crisis is not good for the lebanese
people is it i mean they're already
facing severe economic issues
absolutely i mean lebanon is going
through one of the harshest crisis ever
we have massive we had a massive
devaluation of the currency which made
the purchasing power of the population
shrink so now they can buy way less with
the same wage and with the increase of
prices of weed it will increase poverty
poverty jumped to like 80 percent of the
population 80 to 85 percent of the
population is
is expected to be under poverty line now
and and those expectations would be
higher in case we had either shortage of
wheat or higher prices
now the other dimension is that the bank
subsidizes it
and and is losing the dollar reserve on
that i don't know how much he could
drain those reserve anymore okay patrick
let me bring in uh david into the
conversation and we'll further talk
about uh this region uh and lebanon and
other countries that are heavily reliant
on wheat from ukraine and russia david
uh we are now into the second week of
this conflict in ukraine and wheat
prices have already gone up
do you expect them to to go
up as much as 50 as some people are
predicting and what will that mean for
countries in parts of the middle east
and africa that are very vulnerable
to the price of wheat
so
let's start by saying that even before
the crisis all the prices of these
commodities were pretty high so it's not
like if we have increased by 50 already
from low level so
and that for the global food security we
have to keep this into account before
the crisis we were already in a very uh
potentially gloomy situation
with also some bad harvest coming from
latin america so the markets were
worried and intense and now of course
you create this description where
basically one third or a bit more of the
weed that is globally traded
is um basically a stage of the situation
the only kind of good news is
we are dealing with the last harvest so
there were just you know one third of
the remaining harvest to be shipped from
russia and ukraine
but of course for some countries like
lebanon egypt
um we we talk
in the previous segment you talk about
yemen that
import weed through the wfp also but up
to to pakistan and uh in tunisia going
west or this region
is dependent on this supply on a regular
basis so that's a major uh source of
tension
now uh also what we have to keep in mind
is this is a situation today tomorrow um
countries are planting of course new
crops but they need fertilizer and here
also we have a specific issue that can
put pressure on the next harvest
indeed yes
i will get to that about the the
fertilizer issue because of the
sanctions imposed on russia i just want
to bring in dara to the conversation uh
to get you your initial thoughts dara i
mean most grain flows out of odessa uh
and other western ports on the black sea
and we don't have a clear picture yet of
the extent of of the damage on port
facilities and railroads but what will
be in your opinion the short-term and a
long-term consequences dara of you know
you on ukraine's capacity to move uh its
crop production beyond its borders
well it's going to be um
extremely bad uh at the moment uh what
we're seeing is russian forces have uh
taken a lot of the southern coast of
ukraine that's where their advance has
had the most success
um and if you get to a situation where
most of ukraine's black sea ports are
effectively under an occupation regime
even if you can get the grain to those
facilities um you know there's a
question legally as to whether it can be
exported from there right this is before
we get to the fact that the war itself
is depleting
ukraine's capacity to produce grain this
season both due to direct damage and due
to the diversion of manpower
and just to clarify uh because we we've
heard about the sanctions of course are
the sanctions imposed on on russia dara
are they already impacting third parties
countries that are reliant on russian
exports are
food and fertilizer exports for example
uh being allowed to continue
well the sanctions aren't directly um
affecting those there have been numerous
carve outs uh within the sanctions
regime for certain commodity exports
food included
the question will be what russia itself
decides to do
the kremlin is very aware that inflation
can be a potent political
tool to put pressure on the countries
that are supporting ukraine we've
already seen joseph biden and most of
his
addresses has made inflation and
preventing inflation due to the
sanctions hitting american consumers a
key talking point um it's not clear that
that's within its gift however when it
comes to food um russia even before this
war had reduced its export quota um for
the year ahead fearing the
potential rise in domestic prices we've
also seen a
you know it's a very good point on
fertilizers russia and galleries produce
a huge amount of the world's potash and
they're already talking about
restrictions on that equally natural gas
is one of the
precursor components for a lot of
chemical fertilizers so we could be in a
position where
russia is still able to produce quite a
lot of food
it's restricting
how and where it exports it and it's
also uh restricting the uh the
components for
for fertilizers that are needed for
other countries to grow food and this
creates a pretty powerful inflationary
pressure
in an economic situation where we're
already seeing pretty high levels of
global inflation uh due to the emergence
from the pandemic and that's put
pressure on the political leaders who
are currently supporting ukraine so uh
david darius says you know russia could
use this as a pressure tool but the
russians also are under a great deal of
pressure with these sanctions is there
any way that russian producers can
circumvent these sanctions perhaps
through china for example
so clearly i think that the chinese
market
can be a key key source of opportunities
for russian producers just during the
olympic game for instance
uh
china has accepted to lower their if you
want sanitary standards on some shipment
to receive more grains from russia that
previously were banned from
the markets
still you know what's going to happen in
the black sea and cp grains from the
western part of russia to china is going
to be obviously costly um and there are
some limits to uh to that
um
and i mean the recent government
has uh his own way to control what
exporters are doing so it's not like if
it is really a market economy where
people will try to find all markets on
their own right so
we talked about the fertilizers how are
people going to get the fertilizer they
need to grow more food if they're not
getting it from russia david
so
you know we have different kind of
fertilizers some can be manufactured
from natural gas or coal and here of
course the supply of natural gas and
coal is an issue or the price
um can be an issue and then you have
some fertilizer like potass and
phosphate that are mined from from a
deposit and these deposits are not
available everywhere on earth so we are
going to see the production that can
consistently increase from place like
like canada
actually you know germany their own uh
potash
deposit so but still we are going to see
very high price meaning that
the wealthy farmers and basically the
farmers from
the us from europe are going to be able
to afford it
even if the cost of production will go
up and of course the cost of the grains
they produce will go up but in other
parts of the world that where we can see
really a shortage right we have some
government that subsidized fertilizer
and i think that will be the same
discussion that we had earlier about you
know
how long government can really subsidize
inputs without uh becoming bankrupt but
in other places in particular in africa
we can see sorted with lower production
when we start from situations where
actually they don't use enough
fertilizer in this part of the world and
their yield already very low and that
can be very a big issue speaking of
subsidies
patrick in beirut
let's talk about this region and i want
to talk about egypt in particular the
egyptian government hasn't stopped yet
it's subsidies of bread even though
there are reports that it might do so
and and you know with the current
situation this could mean a lot of
trouble for the egyptian government
right they could lose out fiscally do
you see perhaps other countries in this
region saudi arabia for example with
money from the high oil prices stepping
in to help countries like egypt or even
lebanon to help them subsidize
food
so indeed the last time we had a big
increase in uh in food prices
specifically in the price of bed
of bread it went hand in hand with the
arab spring right with with this unrest
and so there is this constant fear where
basically
the normal thing to do is to let the
price of bread go up because the price
of wheat went up but then you are afraid
of those social tensions i think egypt
is trying to work with
their international partners the usa the
imf and probably the gcc countries in
order to to basically be able to
maintain the higher cost of subsidies
because the higher the the
wheat price
the higher the cost of the subsidy will
be and i think they would be able to do
that they have also been accumulating
good foreign exchange reserve which
would give them more more margin of
money i think lebanon on the other hand
is in a biggest problem i mean the
situation is catastrophic uh the central
bank has been draining the foreign
exchange reserve massively for the past
two years we are at alarming level and
the central bank has been using those
foreign exchange reserve to do two
things to try to anchor the exchange
rate at around twenty thousand
kilometers
by losing dollars and for subsidizing
wheat imports right so those are the two
sources draining lebanon's phone
changing reserves and we already got
where we cannot use them anymore so now
we have a big problem patrick what about
yemen i mean uh the wfp was already
forced to reduce food rations to yemen
uh four for eight million people in
yemen um what impact will the escalation
in the conflict uh in ukraine have on
food aid in yemen and other places that
are in conflict in this region
but i think your other guests are more
are better positioned to answer this
question from my perspective i would say
that
one it will depend on the budget
that the world food program is willing
to allocate to yemen and two it will
depend on supply chain issues related to
the sources of the suite where it will
come from and how much time it will take
to get there all right well let's
suppose a moment gentlemen and and take
a look at how pressure on food supplies
in the past has led to protests and
political upheaval something patrick
alluded to earlier in egypt for example
bread is a staple in every meal cost
increases and shortages triggered the
bread riots in 1977 and fueled the
protest movement that toppled president
hosni mubarak in 2011. tunisia's bread
riots of the 1980s killed more than a
hundred people fears of a repeat have
been simmering ever since and protests
in sudan against the costs of bread and
fuel eventually led to the removal of
long-time president omar al-bashir in
2019. dara let me ask you uh about this
in in lower and middle income countries
like egypt tunisia and sudan we've seen
unrest in the past when when you know
the government brought up the the price
of bread or flour
are we looking at possible unrest now in
other countries in even russia perhaps
if prices keep going up
well it's less likely in russia simply
because
uh
russia is producing a lot of this grain
and the state has a huge direct and
indirect control over the economy um so
it can subsidize those prices and it can
keep prices um at a certain low level if
it wants to um i would expect that the
kremlin will do that if it sees rising
by prices as any sort of threat um
vladimir putin has been talking a lot
about the bolsheviks recently and it was
the bread riots in 1917 that that
overthrew the czar and helped bring home
to power so you're quite right
uh that
you know this this is a staple this is
not a non um this is an obligatory
commodity people do need to eat
what will be interesting going forward
is to see whether russia can use its
export
reserves
as a tool of influence we've seen during
this crisis that
russia has not only faced a kind of
coalition of the west saying the usual
suspects in support of ukraine uh but
has faced a wide range of um countries
that would normally be a little bit more
sympathetic to its position either
abstaining or voting against it in
international for like the u.n
so you know providing grain to countries
that are under duress or regimes where
you know the the government may become
destabilized due to rises
maybe a way for russia to win friends
and influence people assuming it can get
rain to them right uh patrick your
thoughts about uh what what
this could lead to possibly i mean could
this lead to unrest uh in in the middle
east north africa region if prices are
going up and keep going up
uh well i think that there is high risks
of unrest especially that we've been in
a high inflation framework for a while
uh with covet of course uh you had i
mean
we need to separate in the middle east
between oil exporting nations and oil
importing
i don't think that oil export oil and
gas exporting nation would have any
problem per se i think that the problem
is with the other countries those
countries who might have some social
unrest related to the high prices we're
already in a high prices environment and
now with this shock i think prices will
be higher in lebanon we had massive
demonstration in the past two years uh
they were uh protesting corruption uh
and we are heading to an election within
like a couple of months so it's like the
worst time for the political class i
think to run elections right and if they
think about it then you know you you
would have massive disruption and
massive protest
david this war in ukraine today poses a
serious risk to global food security
what should be the response from
governments in your view and and
international organizations
so um obviously one of the responses to
use money um we just see it you know
some of the oil exporter countries can
actually mobilize some of their
financial resources
to support some government that will
have to implement social safety net
to uh
to protect their population at least in
the middle of this crisis but also as we
just discussed wfp the world food
programs uh when the cost of food double
their budget doesn't double
automatically so basically their
proceding power is divided by two so we
also need to to help them and now i
think there is um additional measures
that have to be taken first solidarity
also on this commodity market we don't
want to see a domino effect of export
restriction or export ban that will just
amplify the issue so the last thing that
the world needs to know that india say
in order to fight for the inflation i am
also restricting my my exports
argentina is also a key player that in
many cases due to social unrest at home
and food inflation
tend to put this uh export limit but it
just make the world market smaller and
smaller and people start to panic uh and
buy more and more and so you see really
this paralleling situation as we have
seen in 2007 2008 so you know this
coordination and try to show solidarity
not only in terms of money but also in
terms of commodity last but not least
today we have also large um
just one example of the bad policy that
can exist today we have large biofuel
programs that consume a large share of
grains but also available oil and i just
want to point that the vettable oil
market
is also in turmoil and it's a staple
food for for for many people in
particular when we move uh more in
western asia and east asia and you know
how we can basically reduce the pressure
reduce the demand on what is
non-intentional because feeding people
is essential right um
and that can be kind of response you
know and of course there is more medium
term thinking right uh dara in london
let me get your thoughts on this uh you
know what should governments and
international
organizations do and what are some of
the measures that importing countries
could take to mitigate the drop in
supply
with uh everything that david just said
there um it's not clear what importing
countries can do without the cooperation
and collaboration of exporting countries
and with international financial support
um to get food to people at a reasonable
price you know
if we're going to cushion the impact the
markets on the the final consumers
the question that i would have is
whether governments around the globe
have the bandwidth and the capacity to
do this
the eu and the us are already
quite engaged with the ukraine crisis
they're they're kind of fighting that
fire right now um the u.s will probably
still have
half an eye on its indo-pacific strategy
and potential challenges from china
and the kind of programs that david was
talking about would require a pretty um
global multilateral response to uh to
ensure that fertilizer is the grain that
everything is
shipped worldwide to where it's needed
at a reasonable price and so it's a
coordination issue and something that
you know the globe hasn't been extremely
good at doing in the past but we'll see
what happens as this conflict goes on um
you know whether we get to a point where
the actual fighting in ukraine is
terminated quite quickly and go on to
mitigating its effects uh including on
global markets uh but right now i would
say it's it's difficult to see that
actually happening well thank you to all
of our guests patrick mardini david
labord and dara mcdowell
and thank you for watching you can watch
this program again anytime by visiting
our website at aljazeera.com for further
discussion go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter we are aj inside
story from me fully batibo and the whole
team thanks for watching bye for now